my cell phone why do I have piece of
[ __ ] on there okay here we go alright
y'all here we go okay you can see me and
hear me okay so I got look I got
everything I need I just don't have any
firecrackers I got to go kill some dudes
to get some firecrackers real fast get
these firecrackers y'all yeah I know you
can see me now we're all good we all
good okay here we go
yes what am i doing man I'll check that
out like a [ __ ] ninja up in here
okay first imma kill this piece of [ __ ]
give me your money give me your money
son
give me your money because I want these
firecrackers
I want these firecrackers y'all I want
these firecrackers ah okay wait [ __ ] it
let's just do it well you know what I
gotta go to the main screen so I could
see y'all okay okay okay
is happening
okay
okay here we go all right now I see
everybody okay there we go
hello everybody sorry I'm just getting
this chat and I mean I let me pop the
chat out that's how you do it
pop the chat out so I can make the chat
big boom
there it is Chad has popped out I don't
need to see that boom okay boom
let me show all these things alright
there we go
okay guys who he is here we be let's do
this
okay I need to kill some more dudes
though so I need like a few more
firecrackers maybe right so let me go
kill everybody in this area real fast oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] shot me yeah oh man me
pellets how many [ __ ] pellets that
doesn't make any sense you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go over here and yeah
I'm gonna go back down here and rest
so we could do this right look at me
learn in oh wait you guys think that set
up for the new park
check out let me show y'all what the new
riffing with Grif and I told you I'm
growing check this out y'all
check that out oh look how it looks now
if it would create a fan-favorite river
fan so I put some stuff on the walls you
know what I mean we growing okay what do
I do
wait I rest okay alright here we go here
we go okay now I'm ready to do it I got
two firecrackers if I kill two more
dudes I could get some more firecrackers
situation and that's what we need to do
I need to kill this piece of [ __ ] okay
take his money take his money all right
let's go get this guy just another guy
right here here we go here we got his
money
okay how many is that three god damn I
need another one oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what we can go kill this big dude
go fast
wait where is he where isn't oh [ __ ]
come on here
yes
oh man to gain a man the game just opens
up when you open up all these abilities
man
okay okay nice nice Oh check no look
wait look up my ninja skills there we go
okay I think that's enough firecracker I
got like at least three firecrackers all
right let's go kill this force dude I
have to kill the horse dude
okay let me make this a little bigger
because I can't see the chat cuz ya'll
type in this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm old I
can't see the [ __ ] text on my chance
ridiculous okay there we go alright
alright guys here we go
so is it let's do this [ __ ] only 30% use
okay here we go here we go
[ __ ] get Amana oh [ __ ] how's it
going oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay okay oh yeah
this is it this is this son
oh my god this is so much easier with
that [ __ ] grapple attack oh my god
this is insane
oh [ __ ]
I got a gourd and I got a gourd it up
y'all
Lord it
well this is it
god damn it I don't want to use another
board oh [ __ ]
damn it damn resurrected [ __ ] it static
this is a test run it's my first one
oh yeah Oh almost did you see that oh my
god dude oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay that was good run I'm not
mad at that run at all thank you very
much I am not mad at all
all right here we go all right here we
go we don't do that again y'all we don't
do that again
okay I go that was a test run you know
you got to get your test run in you know
what I mean I'm gonna skip this kill
this mother [ __ ]
so I can get some more firecrackers
got you gotta kill two guys just to get
one of those things I think right this
game reminds me of Game of Thrones I
thoroughly enjoyed the first episode of
Game of Thrones you know I don't know if
you guys watched it I don't know if Game
of Thrones fans out there but I really
enjoyed that first episode they had to
turn this so yes I can see it better
there we go okay here we go
that can't be [ __ ] around I gotta run
I gotta run I gotta run oh [ __ ]
oh my god dude my god oh my god okay you
know what it was I got greedy on that I
got greedy on that one I know damn don't
get so greedy I totally agree
see that was greedy that was greedy it
was greedy that was greedy we got this
damn was greedy and we can't be greedy
boom boom boom boom don't be greedy oh
my god I know I know oh my god Pikachu
don't even [ __ ] start with me right
now I swear to God you know what I'm not
even gonna kill this guy today we are
just going right for the horse man right
for the horse man okay I got it guys I
was greedy on that one but he believed
that I almost killed the horse man
already without even having any of these
abilities I mean that's the crazy part
so I totally need to do it now
[Music]
okay that was it
here we go don't get greedy don't get
greedy two three run oh [ __ ]
okay I got greedy I got greedy on that
one you can't get you gotta get two hits
I'll try to get three one time I got
four though
this is it this is it
we got him don't get greedy one two
firecrackers what happened
oh [ __ ] you know what [ __ ] this I'm not
even gonna court it go get greedy
run but run Forrest okay Gord it warned
it
Gord it
[Music]
okay here we go here we go y'all this is
it [ __ ] okay here we go we got a
run we got a run though well this is it
it's about you got to see it happen
okay this is it come on come on keep
take it there oh [ __ ]
yeah dammit I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] up
[ __ ] man resurrect
don't get greedy okay Gordon Gordon No
oh my god oh my god what am i doing
what am i doing dude run from this
[ __ ] or is he
Oh
oh my god oh my god okay okay
III Gore did it at the wrong time dude
that was over Gordon we over Gord it
okay let's just be real about what
happened we over Gord it I tried to use
the firecrackers but I switched it off
I'm pressing the wrong button for the
firecrackers that's what happened and I
switched it to the axe by accident okay
sorry all right we overcome late week
over week over oh okay see no we don't
want the [ __ ] flames we want dad wait
what if why there's two firecrackers you
know what I got to get some more
firecrackers come on get the [ __ ] up
there [ __ ]
you know we got to get some crackers we
got to get these crackers we gotta get
these crackers or the game how come did
they give me any crackers I killed two
guys maybe you can't kill the same guys
more than once is that what it is okay
okay oh my god dude
[ __ ] wait let me get back over here hold
on I got to relax a second
okay but we got it we got it
now here's is it this is yet did Susan
oh where am I going
oh I wanted to use some more
firecrackers that's right we are the
guys here
oh [ __ ] nope nope
[Music]
okay
we got it [ __ ] saw me oh my god
nice all [ __ ] do some other [ __ ] are
trying their best
ah I got that [ __ ] okay that's
all be these three firecrackers that's
good enough that's good enough
oh [ __ ] oh my god
okay okay we got three firecrackers okay
here we go this is it this is the one
god this is gonna be the run this is
going to be the run of Champions yes
that was said don't be greedy YouTube
one more one more
back it up back it up
yes that was it that's it okay
okay no no we're not gonna be greedy I
wasn't I wasn't feeling that one here we
go here we go ah okay
don't be greedy don't be greedy
okay give it to him give it to him back
up back it up back it up okay okay okay
okay back it up oh this is the one I
feel it I feel this one okay give it to
him back it up back it up back it up
back it up back it up back it up back it
up this is it this is it this is the one
he's going down right now y'all oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] him up
one more time one more time
[ __ ] what am i doing guys what am i saw
my god oh my gosh oh my god that was it
I had it right there you know what I
might give up though yeah I'm not gonna
forward it I'm not gonna do that to my
children
there we go okay get out of here run
[ __ ] run for us [ __ ] did you see that
I got a gourd it I got a gourd it oh
[ __ ] okay here we go here we go here we
go no no oh my god
oh my god
that's it that's it that's it that's it
there we go here we go
don't overdo it breathe
oh [ __ ] okay
I got it Gordon I gotta go record it
okay there it is stir this we're all
right we're all right oh my god I got a
Gordon last chord I'm sweating like a
[ __ ] right now
[Music]
get up get up get up oh my god
Ron [ __ ] where Z where Z oh my god dude
[Music]
no what oh I'm not dead I'm not dead
look at this oh my god I gotta move move
[ __ ] Rob oh my god
oh my god face him this is it
Ron Ron just Oh God okay here we go
come on get you oh my god I can't
believe this
okay okay this is it oh [ __ ] I missed my
attack No
oh wait
Oh hit hit again
oh yeah oh my god Gus live on stream
live on Griffin gaming so we do it god
damn it we killed that piece of [ __ ]
killed that piece of shirt whoo
okay okay oh [ __ ]
all right how do you that was snow
smells fantastic
oh that's fantastic y'all sweating this
[ __ ] okay whoo
I don't even know what to do now
remember each okay I got some new [ __ ]
uh-oh
I mean that was crazy
I'm off me I'm sweaty oh my god that was
whoo let's calm down y'all let's calm
down
we did it where's my gamer goo should I
have my gamer good with me you know okay
I'm chill now now I don't even know what
to do now I mean this might be it
that might be it it didn't take three
months [ __ ]
oh my god all right now you know what we
need to go do is we need to go kill that
[ __ ] staff guy that's what we need to
kill yes okay so I did that
let's go kill the staff guy but how do
you get back - wait wait wait oh I could
go up here now no no no no no what the
[ __ ] am I talking about
wait this guy came from over here wait
don't go over here there's a [ __ ] over
here oh yes there is
I see yes there's one of these right
here
perfect so you open this first
all right that's the new area okay I
needs a commune
[Music]
okay we did that [ __ ] okay umm fent
attack power options have been unlocked
in the sculptors Idol okay okay acquire
skills oh look at just that enhanced
attack power what does that mean what do
you do
I don't come oh I don't know what oh the
battle memory of an extraordinary foe
although distant relatives such as okay
nobody once led a group okay
attack power has been enhanced oh oh I
see oh I shouldn't have done that okay I
see I should have waited to use that to
kill somebody
yes on us yeah I saw us chat I liked it
I just didn't like the story in the end
okay so we acquire skills wait how many
of these things do I have where we I
need to go here
I don't know what to do here just kind
of wild just kind of ill wait I need to
see how many wait wait wait Oh next
skill point is 55 points we only have
one okay wait I get someone knit nod and
get any new [ __ ] there what's that I
don't get it I don't know what to do
next
well you know I don't got any merch yet
but I will but there's always super chat
don't be bashful with that super chat
don't be bashful with that FUBU chat ok
I need to figure out what I need to do
next okay but here's the skills
grappling hook attack okay I got all
that should know buddy but okay okay I
need to go kill this [ __ ]
all right I need to go kill wait I need
to go kill this guy now that's what I
need to do yeah I need to go kill this
dude over here guys
you know what I mean and he should have
to make this bigger is a stupid
I'll keep this here
okay here we go
oh I'm ok wait wait wait what do you
mean I missed a skill tree right let's
go
yeah but see I don't have enough skill
points to open that up yet you know what
I mean but I do have to open it up I
have one skill point and I'm so close to
getting another one so what I need to do
is just kill [ __ ] over here and get
to skill point how about that right you
know what I need to do is I need to go
kill this fire guy first let's go kill
this fire piece of [ __ ] first
well you which one is the guy shooting
the arrows so that guy see me I mean you
would think they would see you you look
you're [ __ ] on a freaking roof yeah
like come on hey why can't I get up
there there we go
all right here we go here we go all
right
your [ __ ] money [ __ ] oh you awful
you [ __ ] where right now I'm
dangerous
oh [ __ ] another guy another arrow dude
oh [ __ ] okay alright okay I have two
skill points alright here we go oh [ __ ]
I got to go back to this thing just go
back here
here we go here we go
okay a choir skill here we go right I
gotta open up this tree yes you missed
it I got past the horse dude
son got past him okay I got to change
the title of this
this is the gun become oh my god what
the hell
no I said good name for it on your foot
wait go back to the horse dudes fire
oh that missed something there Oh God
this is what I'm talking about I don't
know what I'm doing okay here we go
all right the shinobi martial art run
and slide allows you to slide into a
crouched position while sprinting sprint
through an area okay how do you [ __ ] do
you do it while sprinting oh okay
and what is this one acquire the latent
skills suppressed but latent skill that
reduces an enemy's ability to perceive
those who are in a stealth remove ones
presence is a part of what oh wow look
at all that I had look at what I've done
without any of this [ __ ] my god dude
okay let's travel back to the horse guy
okay
uh come on what the [ __ ] all right
oh this is what divorce guy is right
here we go here we go what's up y'all
Sean Collins hello I wish I can make the
[ __ ] chat bigger too stupid I wish I
had to cheat codes oh I know cheat codes
what's up everybody y'all better go back
and look at the beginning of this video
because daddy beat ojos dude why so I
got to go here what the [ __ ] here oh I
just got killed
oh no you know what you right i should
pop to chat out
ha shoutout
target time stamps
top chat out there it is
they have announced they so little
this text bigger
okay
this is the fire does not owe this fire
wait there's something in here my
[ __ ] missing something here
where is this [ __ ]
okay there's three fires like I saw that
one that one
is it this one no this one no is it this
one
No
okay guys what [ __ ] fire am I looking
for
Oh what's in here
how do you open that door
okay zip this one what am I looking for
you set fire where is of the stairs you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] told me to go
to the fires god damn it
okay what the [ __ ] up here this guy
dead Oh discussed it over there
this ain't it oh this fire no oh look is
it dude here okay purchase items oh [ __ ]
okay what do I need to purchase I don't
need to purchase [ __ ] huh and you know
what I know I should sell [ __ ] huh no
cuz then I'm gonna die and it's gonna be
useless is this is this what you guys
are saying for me to go okay cuz I am
like [ __ ] turned around right now huh
where am I supposed to go from here is
this what you wanted me to go to this I
am turn to [ __ ] around Oh should I just
messed up this dude fire I'd be pissed
oh here we go
you talk about in here right okay just
make sense now got me that pallet I
could open this door now oh [ __ ] look at
this oh this is like okay
now I don't have to go through all that
[ __ ] right so I need to talk to this
[ __ ] right yes I'm reading this piece
of [ __ ] tell me on I'm okay whatever
dying okay bro first up okay I don't
really want to read this set kiddo that
is no time soon maybe you are sick okay
bro do I accept this
i'ma wait because you guys are behind
you guys are behind me like 30 seconds
so i'ma wait do I accept this chat
what's the deal no you shouldn't roast
me Cody Marshall
guys are you gonna tell me if I should
oh there's Randy I didn't see Randy was
in here
Randhir e-cig dude this guy's a that's
guys a rocker I see you in there Randy
Randy made that he made a dope-ass song
for me
Thank You Randy oh except okay so I took
except at description the ratchet Gibson
have snuck into the speaks of okay
the rats assassins frontal cause short
stature were a number of rats are
looking I've seen around okay do I talk
to him again no okay now we gotta go
upstairs what's upstairs
and [ __ ] upstairs oh here we go you
right you right
oh yes give me that light corn purse
okay I mean should I sell some [ __ ]
though oh look at this oh no these are
should I already have a bet
no it's still the same thing how do you
unlock that [ __ ]
oh the rats are the small dudes right
you have to kill those guys got it got
it got it okay so what I need to figure
out though is do I need to set should I
go sell this light coin purse to buy
some [ __ ] like do I need some [ __ ]
bought you know what I mean all right
this is good to know that this guy's
right here okay I need to sell items huh
oh I got plenty of pellets Wow look at
my [ __ ] I got this is don't wait that's
it oh I'm selling my bad sell items I'm
not gonna give you that [ __ ] what's the
sugar for I have so much [ __ ] these
ceramic things like bye [ __ ] bye like
those are [ __ ] useless you know what
I mean okay
should I so let me show this light coin
purse okay
black gun thing okay I won't sell that
okay purchase it what should I buy paint
buy [ __ ] oh my god you need a thousand
for what
wait I have 325 I wonder if I should
attempt to man I should have kept that
light going per point purse this is
gonna be a nightmare
I'm never gonna get it may the departed
rest in peace all right okay
this was cool and all but now I need to
go kill this I need to go kill the spear
guy all right I'm gonna go kill the
spear guy
oh no you see again I don't have any
purchase I got a purchase spirit emblems
just so I can kill those stupid yeah I
need to go kill those stupid guys Oh
will you alright I see what you're
saying so the coin purse if when you buy
the coin purse you don't ever lose the
money if you die is that what happens
you know what that makes sense to me now
that's what the coin course is for okay
I'm going back to get the coin purse
okay I've totally get it I totally get
it got it I got it guys I got it I'm
learning [ __ ] god yeah y'all don't gotta
be so [ __ ] let's see I can only buy
two okay look I did it see all right now
I get it
it's making so much sense to me now
somebody why do you lose all your
[ __ ] money okay here we go
all right here we go okay now we're
gonna go kill no I can't twitch and
YouTube at the same time anymore guys
cuz I'm now a twitch affiliate so now
it's just you just don't - we just - but
y'all we just to do all we doing is -
Ben - Ben like Ruben
[Music]
hunt rats first to upgrade the arm think
so no no you know what I could kill that
guy I could kill that guy I could kill
this pole guy I could kill this poor guy
I wanted to kill the poor guy first all
right here we go y'all here we go yo
so guys coming soon you know I got
regular episodes of riff on where
Griffin come in but the check out to
Griffin with Griffith studio how was
coming together y'all oh oh [ __ ] what is
that backdrop yo we got backdrop with
with Griffith Studios coming together
with a great fan
all right you saw it
yes I was filming guesthouse and it's
done I'm finished today I rap today on
guest house y'all
okay which one is the
what
not damn it
okay so now I got a [ __ ] pellet I got
a I got a cod damn it
guys I want the Leigh brothers we're
going you know they're not they're not
gonna be off for a little while okay
they'll come back but right now we're
dealing with some things so they're not
going to come on yet okay
so relax what is that right there oh
wait how come I can't grab that dousing
powder what the [ __ ] that oh my god I
should go rest it's like I don't want to
use a gourd already right
there we go
okay here we go y'all
I may say should I just kill these [ __ ]
real fast or no I should go yeah yeah
you know what I'm just gonna kill these
[ __ ] okay all right here we go
wait wait wait wait no no oh I've never
used a fistful of ash I should use that
every now and then you know what I mean
I wonder will that work on the the one
the guy that'll be dopest of worked on
oh okay
so we now we got a bucket here we go
there we go y'all
how come I can't get up there what that
is so [ __ ] annoying okay done
done I'll give me I'm good we take all
this [ __ ] we take all this [ __ ] oh now I
understand how to save money you just
have to go to one of those guys and buy
a light okay now it makes sense huh
alright guys thanks for worse take it
off I'm getting Jeremiah on I'm just
going to Pittsburgh tomorrow I'm going
to Pittsburgh this weekend and I already
got some podcasts in the bank I also
want to do my Game of Thrones review
version of the podcast midweek so look
out for that if you're into it okay here
we go
okay I want to switch it up and use fire
okay okay oh you know what I want to do
is I'm gonna kill the [ __ ] I want to
kill the [ __ ] this guy first wait
where's the [ __ ] bow guy is that him
right there is that the bow guy no
that's not to bow guy
where the hell's the bow guy well here
he is here yes you gotta kill this
[ __ ] first this is not where I want it
to go it's so infuriating
oh I know I got to work on these
counters you're right you got a skid
let's get this yeah smash to like y'all
do they see me
oh my god don't aside that old
commercial okay here we go
all right I don't think I'm gonna be
able to do this guy tonight so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go save my money
no no no man is there another no there
isn't I got to get past this guy
Oh God well I think this was a very
productive stream guys very productive
stream
right we killed the horse guy that's
what we've been trying to do for a while
now whoa see it's like they still see me
yeah the guy still sees me I don't know
where this other guy is there he is
there he is
yes yes son okay well we got it out I
gotta go over here and kill I gotta kill
those guys over there cuz they will get
in the way where's this guy yet he's way
up there I think I can sneak around here
and kill these guys or not or not
that was useless
all right that's it I did it
okay well horse guy has been killed
thank you for the dollar ninety-nine for
the horse man's funeral cost I
appreciate that you guys have been great
I knew I could do it and I did it horse
man dead good riddance bye horse man
bye-bye body stream thank you for
watching I did it horse made a piece out